[Music]
the redband trailer for james guns a
suicide squad is finally here
and everyone's freaking out the trailer
features the best look yet to this
ambitious and fun film from the horribly
beautiful mind of the guardians of the
galaxy filmmaker
and it's packed with small details you
just might have missed
at various points in the trailer we see
scenes set somewhere with palm trees and
a weapon-toting military
what is this place it's a fictional
island nation in latin america
that we know from previous reports is
called corto maltese
the suicide squad producer peter saffron
previously explained the significance of
the island
and why the suicide squad is going there
in the first place
there they have to destroy a nazi era
prison and laboratory named jotunheim
it's a place where political prisoners
were held and experimentations took
place
corto maltese's military has more than
his fair share of encounters with the
squad
and by the looks of it they're being led
by major general martial
soros who's played by joaquin cosio of
narcos fame
as gunn revealed in a post he shared on
twitter in september 2020
he wrote the role specifically for kosio
but major general matteo suarez
doesn't appear to have any counterpart
in the page of dc
comics the field commander of task force
x aka the suicide squad is rick flack
who's seen in the trailer rescuing
harley
and teaching the new recruits the ropes
all the while he's wearing a bright
yellow shirt featuring a cartoon rabbit
the critter is wearing a red cape and a
shirt that has the warner brothers wb
logo on it and holding a sign that reads
obstacular sun opportunities or in
spanish
obstacles opportunities at first glance
it's just a cute costume choice
but there's actually a story behind it
the rabbit might possibly be a reference
to bugs bunny
warner brother's famous cartoon
character while his cape could be a nod
to another character
of brothers says the screen writes to
superman together with the obstacles
opportunity sign the shirt could read as
a reference to james gunn's obstacle
of being fired by disney from his gig
directing guardians of the galaxy vol 3
back in 2018. only to then be presented
the opportunity of being hired by warner
brothers
to direct the suicide squad according to
the hollywood reporter
gum was even offered a chance to work on
a new superman movie
but he chose this wacky ensemble project
instead
following that disney decided to hire
him back for guardians volume 3 anyway
giving him a situation that may just be
the best of both worlds
we've known for a while that king shark
would be a major player in the suicide
squad
but there wasn't much conversation
surrounding the character's casting
apart from reports that steve agee was
serving as the onset stand-in
but the lucky actor who would actually
be voicing the royal fishman was totally
a mystery
until now after the release of the
trailer which features a shockingly
realistic looking king shark
getting up to some upsettingly violent
activities gunn took to twitter to let
everyone know that it's none other than
sylvester stallone
providing the voice for the aquatic
anti-hero stallone also
addressed his casting on twitter sharing
a hilariously typoed post that reads
okay shark coming your way the new
suicide squad is thundering your way
august 8th the reveal that stallone
voices king shark in the suicide squad
was much needed and much appreciated as
many viewers probably didn't catch the
rocky actor's voice
when watching the trailer the first time
around given he only said
nom nom and hand and
yes that is your hand very good
this is the second time stallone and
gunn have linked up
with the former taking on the role of
ravager captains takara oh god
in guardians of the galaxy vol 2. he's
not the only guardians of the galaxy 2
alum showing up in the suicide squad
either
yondu actor michael rooker portrays
cervanteer and
gunn's brother sean who both stands in
for rocket on set
and plays craiglin in the guardians
movies portrays weasel in the upcoming
film john ostrander has left a
significant mark on the superhero
landscape
he's written stories for the x-men
batman the punisher
and more across a nearly 40-year career
in the comic book industry
maybe his most famous contribution to
the medium though came in dc's legends
number one
which introduced a fresh reimagining of
task force x
and their never before seen handler
amanda waller
it wouldn't be overstating things to say
that ostrander is largely responsible
for the suicide squad we're all familiar
with today
so it's appropriate that james gunn
found a spot for him in the upcoming
film
at the new trailer's 53 second mark
viewers see michael ruckus savants at
the receiving end of a needle
full of remote controlled explosives the
doctor administering the injection is
played by none other than ostrander
the cameo was confirmed by gun in a
twitter post where he stated
it only makes sense that the actual
creator of the suicide squad
is the one to put the bombs in their
heads talk about meeting your maker
amongst the several members of the squad
featured in the trailer there are a few
faces obviously missing
however if you have an eye for detail
you'll pick up on hints of them amongst
the chaos
near the end of the trailer for the
suicide squad there's a quick glimpse of
one of the movie's brand new characters
sol soria played by i am legends alisa
braga
solsoria isn't a character from the dc
comics but rather a character made just
for the film
that is unless she's actually a female
version of the justice league obsessed
joanne sawyer
who was rejected from joining the group
and wound up in the bel reeve
penitentiary
before very briefly joining the suicide
squad near the very beginning of the
trailer when amanda waller is looking at
harley quinn's file
there's a second one beneath it that
seems to hint at one of the suicide
squad's other newcomers
mongal while the file is mostly cut off
the details in it include things like
alien and
orange which are pretty up descriptions
of the super strong extraterrestrial
character
mangal is being played in the movie by
martial artist mei ling
ung who did stunts for wonder woman with
mass homicide and war crimes listed in
mongao's file
she definitely fits in among the other
criminals of task force x
fund's fundamental but at the end of the
day a long-term relationship with a
clown is nobody's proudest achievement
it's the sort of thing you carry for a
while then you might take out your
frustrations on the people around you
either with harsh rhetoric or a giant
wooden mallet
harley quinn has historically gone with
a little of column a and a little of
column b
so it shouldn't be surprising that she
displays a variety of possible coping
mechanisms in the suicide squad's
trailer
though harley is very much her own
person in a post-joker world
that doesn't mean she doesn't hold a
grudge and what might be a particularly
sly dig on her former beau
she tells the thinker if we find out you
have personalized license plates
you don't characteristically zany for
sure
but it has added meaning when you
remember that joker had vanity license
plates on his car
in the first suicide squad somehow he
held out on snatching up a
hahaha valentine plate until 2017 which
is a testament to his 80 odd years of
self-control
and not for nothing but harley's also
rocking some new ink these days
in the film's trailer she sports a
tattoo that reads property of no one
her pudding days are clearly behind her
there's a familiar face hidden in the
suicide squads trailer
if you look close enough and this not
sylvester stallone is a shark
during the brief party scene you'll
notice an older gentleman
desperately clinging to a young woman on
the dance floor that man is none other
than lloyd kaufman
the co-founder of troma entertainment
you may know him as the co-director and
co-writer of the 1984 cult classic
the toxic avenger or the multi-talented
mind behind many
other trauma productions gunn actually
got his start at troma entertainment
when he wrote 1995's tromeo and juliet
with korff muniz's mentor
since then gunner's been plugging
kaufman into cameo appearances with
astonishing regularity
kaufman appeared in guns 2006 horror
flick slither
his 2010 dark superhero deconstruction
super
and even as a prisoner in 2014's
guardians of the galaxy
coincidentally kaufman used to
collaborate regularly with john g
wildson the director of rocky and had
cameo appearances in both rocky and
rocky 5
making the suicide squad another notch
in his tally of sylvester stallone
team-ups as well
when a group of villains get together to
take down one big bad villain
things tend to get crazy quickly last
time around the titular squad was sent
on a mission to defeat enchantress
but in the latest adventure the major
threat appears to be far more
seafood in nature yes it seems fans are
going to get a good look at the giant
alien starfish known as starro the
conqueror
after a mounting to nothing more than
just a quick easter egg in zack snyder's
justice league
starro gets placed front and center in
the trailer for the suicide squad
oh my god we've gotta freaking kaiju up
in this
star rose had various powers over the
years but the most noteworthy is its
mind control abilities
seeing as how it's apparently been kept
hidden on corto maltese
it's possible the villains there have
been trying to figure out a way to
harness its powers
to control the masses or maybe it's the
other way around and they're all under
starro's control
with gun at the helm literally anything
is possible so there's only one way to
find out
marky calendars for the suicide squad to
hit theaters and hbo max
on august 6th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one